-Thank you so much for
coming back and being here.
I do want to get into your tour,
"Patton Oswalt Live."
If you want to see
a great comedian,
please check out Patton Oswalt.
You're doing Friday, September
17th, Washington, D.C.,
at the Kennedy Center
Concert Hall.
Two shows.
That's a big jam right there.
-Yeah.
-On the 18th at Virginia Beach
at Sandler Center
for Performing Arts.
You got like 20 dates on here.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's been amazing. It's been --
I'm in front of
live audiences again,
and it's great enough
to be, like, hearing --
like, I'm so used to being
inside, so it's all emojis
and thumbs-up over the Internet
when I'm tweeting
or texting someone.
And now I'm like, "What's that
noise coming out --
Oh, that's laughter. Oh, yeah.
That's laughter."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay."
-I was scared.
-But what's weird is
a lot of times it's entertaining
not even for the laughter.
It feels like me and the
audience are checking in
with each other just to confirm
that none of us
has gone completely crazy.
So when I'm on stage and go,
"So I had, like,
Doritos for breakfast,"
and they're like,
"We had Doritos!"
Okay, good. We didn't go crazy.
Good, we're all
on the same page."
-Did you pour Pepsi over yours?
-Okay, good, yeah, great, I kind
of went crazy for a little.
So we all are confirming that
our minds broke
during quarantine
and during the shutdowns.
-I know you got in some news,
some headlines, last two weeks
or something like that because
you had to cancel some shows.
-I canceled some shows
because the venues --
It wasn't really
the venues' fault.
There were four shows in Florida
that unfortunately right now
they don't let these venues
enforce COVID protocols because
it's against the law for them.
And then there was another gig
in Salt Lake City.
I had to cancel
and it killed me.
I love going to Florida.
It would have been in December.
And then I -- But then I started
getting all this weird push.
90% of the feedback
was very positive.
"Thank you, we'll see you in the
future when things are saner."
I did get the even split between
"You're a Nazi for demanding
the cards," 'cause, yeah,
that was Hitler's big thing,
was making sure
that no one was vaccinated.
[ Laughter ]
And then also, but I also got --
-Was that his big thing?
-That was his big thing.
"Hey, don't get the --"
-That's right. You're right.
-"Listen to me. Horse paste.
Make sure they use
the horse paste."
And then the other one --
-Horse paste.
-I either get that or I get
the "You're a pussy."
And I was like, "Why -- When did
everyone become Thanos
where it's just like,
'Whoever dies, dies.
Just go out there.'"
And by the way, if that is your
philosophy, don't die for a --
Go die seeing Lizzo.
Like, that's a good...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...last concert to see.
-Wait, no, no, no!
You shouldn't die!
-By the way, you shouldn't die
for any entertainer.
But if you are, make it count.
-Not you.
-Don't be in the hospital going,
"I'm so glad I got to see
that fat nerd whine about
'The Mandalorian.'"
[ Imitates flatline ]
[ Laughter ]
That's a terrible final -- That
shouldn't be your last thing!
Don't roll the dice
for that stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-If you want to laugh safely,
please go see Patton.
I want to talk about "A.P. Bio."
Season 4 now is on Peacock.
And one of your costars
is one of my old pals,
my old favorites, one of
the funniest humans, Paula Pell.
-Paula Pell is such a -- She was
already a force as a writer.
Now she's acting on the show.
There are so many scenes
where they were shooting
over my shoulder
and I would blow the scene.
There's one scene in the first
episode where she describes
her grandfathers being killed by
a tornado,
and she describes it like --
I think it's
two balloons full of SpaghettiOs
in the air.
And I'm laughing so hard,
I blew so many takes
because my shoulders
were going up and down.
I'm like hunched over laughing,
and they're like, "No, no,
she's telling you a serious --
You can't be laughing at her..."
-She's unbelievable.
-"...because it makes you
look like a psychopath."
And so many things
that you loved on "SNL,"
she was the brains behind.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Patton Oswalt and Paula
Pell in Season 4 of "A.P. Bio."
Take a look at this.
-Mama, it's Ralph.
I want to thank you for treating
me like a second-class citizen.
I became stronger
because I had to be!
You messed me up!
Thank you!
-[ Clapping ]
Ralph Durbin,
you're a goddamn tiger.
-[ Roars ]
-Now you're ready.
-Hello, Don? Yeah, it's Ralph.
Listen, those price hikes,
they're not going to
work for me, bud.
I'm not paying a penny more
for those tots.
Good. Good.
I'm glad you see it my way.
Oh, Daphne says hi?
Well, you can tell your wife
to kiss my ass!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No!
Patton Oswalt, everybody
Season 4 of "A.P. Bio" is
streaming now on Peacock,
and you can check him out
live on tour.